Jericho but it's gonna be men to sweep
whatever happens cut to the chase
are you going to table a confidence
motion if the Prime Minister loses the
meaningful votes on Tuesday on Tuesday
night or Wednesday after wait and see it
is a matter of confidence because if the
government can't command a majority of
the house and last week they were found
in contempt at the house on emotion
there than in normal political times in
British history that government would
then resign and either make way for
another government or resign all
together in court a general election so
are you making plans to try and try to
form a minority government listen we are
ready to step in and negotiate seriously
the European Union to put up a serious
alternative so you could maybe get that
opportunity to put your version of
brexit to the negotiators we think you
might be able to achieve that without an
election if that is what is on offer and
that becomes a possibility we would do
that is that why Parliament that despite
different political heritage you have
been speaking some language that the DUP
can live with well they clearly dislike
the backstop for very good and very
sensible reasons that yes you have an
open border between northern ireland the
republic but in reality if you then
transfer that border to the irish sea
you've then created a border and a
problem within the UK so problem your
jeremy corbyn's version of brings in
work for the DUP absolutely can work for
the people of Northern Ireland and of
course the people of the Republic of
Ireland is Brandt I'm not everybody's
particularly happy with that position
with you echoing some of the DEP
language or sister party in Northern
Ireland has suggested that this is not
the right approach others in Brussels
suggest you may have backed the backstop
privately when talking to Michelle
Barney oh no they
I'm not quite sure why they would get
that from because they clearly weren't
present when I was talking to me shot
Barney a you've always been against this
type of we've said from the very
beginning that there has to be a trade
and customs arrangement with Europe that
protects all the rights and conditions
that are talked about but also is a
customs union that would enable us to
trade with Europe with a say in it and
without distinctions between different
parts of the UK and if there is a
customs union then of course the the
issue of the Irish Sea water doesn't
apply you don't have any time to
renegotiate the clock is ticking it's
the end of March well listen if we go
into government straight away we'd start
negotiating straight away if it meant
holding things a bit longer to do it of
course but the urgency would be to say
look these are what we want to achieve
these are our objective I've made that
very clear
Europe is very well aware of that it's
been made clear by me and by my team
well you can see an argument for
extending article 50 that's an argument
may come up your good friend the United
secretary general suggested that a
second referendum would be a betrayal do
you agree well I'm not quite sure in
what context he said that I think people
feel that if you simply go to anyone who
vote in the referendum say sorry you got
it wrong you've got to take the vote
again that's not reasonable and that's
not sensible
the ground has shifted now where you
could say they've had a go and hasn't
worked and maybe we need to look again
it I think it's fair to say hasn't
worked because this government has not
succeeded in making it work because of
the way they approached the negotiations
and the arrangements they brought back
which locks us into in all possibility a
backstop which we can only leave if the
EU allows us to leave what is your
message you saw these bags at your
conference love Corbin hates brexit
there's a load of young people in your
party on bulk of your membership once a
second referendum and want the option to
remain are they wrong no they're not
wrong but the option is there
our motion but relations remain what I
just saved them the priority is we don't
get anywhere until we've defeated this
deal that the government is put up
nearly we thought you might be involved
in a debate this Sunday hmm hasn't
happened Prime Minister so you're
running away what that's what you say
well listen she offered a debate I
accepted it four minutes after it was
off of it so does not make the case you
know Skye's campaign to take the
politics out of it to take the you know
all the broadcaster's interests out of
it and have an independent commission to
make this happen as it happens in
America I think you're right because
there is an issue television debates
discussion social media debates
discussion are actually an intrinsic
part of our political life absolutely so
and I think in the last general election
it was regrettable more than regrettable
but the Prime Minister refused to take
part in any of those discussions of
debates
I think they should happen and the
suggestion you've got which is of
essentially an independent body saying
this is how it's going to happen and
when it's going to happen that might
work better